viens c'est
[Musique]
j'espère que vous passez une aussi belle
soirée que nous bonsoir karim bonsoir
calypso ça va bien
vous êtes détendu tout va bien
votre belle histoire d'amour a commencé
d'abord par une histoire d'amitié
oui c'est ça on s'est connu à 5 ans est
vraiment non il ya cinq ans signé
ensemble et on s'est connus ya à peu
près 7 1
7 ans au brésil la grande île était en
couple a choisi donc remettons tout en
place donc vous avez vous avez voyagé au
brésil ma tante était en couple j'étais
un couple calypso c'était une amie on a
une connaissance je connais super bien
son frère alors rassure moi avant de
vous mettre ensemble tu as que tu as
quitté thatta première chéri donc en
fait votre passion commune c'est le
voyage
vraiment vous êtes partis vivre ensemble
ensuite en guadeloupe pour audi et c'est
là que votre amour a pu éclore au soleil
bon alors c'est une telle méthode or ça
je l'aimé beaucoup aujourd'hui vous
habitez où on habite avis sur la sorgue
mais on repartirait en guadeloupe non
bon alors quelle bonne nouvelle oui
dites moi que le mariage être en
guadeloupe on espère fortement on va
tout faire pour le faire là bas
justement ça s'est très très bien dans
la caméra cachée calypso tu es enceinte
oui aujourd'hui vous avez un bébé via
que l'âge il a cyniquement et il
s'appelle comment ado adam moi c'est
beau on va découvrir on va revivre
ensemble cette caméra cachée juste
dingue toi tu vas pouvoir voir les
choses que tu n'as pas vu que tu aperçu
d'une autre manière et tu vas voir tout
ce qu'on a fait pour toi et pour te
faire plaisir
regardez
[Musique]
coucou
les aravis rect
oui exactement
c'est avec ce look et une nana génial et
son chéri tu sais c'est karim je suis
touché
j'ai appris c'est un bel événement là tu
arrives oui ça pousse ça pousse ça
pousse ça pousse surtout que tu es
radieuse pour vaquer chez entre tous
cool j'ai l'impression
et à moi je vous fais combien c'est avec
un peu de pression mais je voudrais
qu'on tient bon jeu génial
gros bisous et merci bourgeat savait
très cool ça va être cool chacun
avec cyril on décide de faire venir
calypso à paris pour sa demande en
mariage surprise à karim
[Musique]
zaiter voyage unique alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est
le grand jury a bien dormi ouais savoir
20 bornes à
tout va s'accélérer maintenant on a fait
venir karim à paris grâce à famille son
meilleur ami e s
on a fait de moi un karine silla vega
mis deux jours à paris pour aller
visiter clairefontaine
l'entreprise basée au quai elie accrue
directement du rex ce sera un autre
cadeau à la planète je viens plus beau
c'est parti je vais présenter à calypso
nos équipes qui installe nos caméras
cachées qui vont l'aider à piège et
carré
[Musique]
bien gérer les caméras de part et
d'autre voilà et bonjour ça je te
présente philippe qui est le réalisateur
et touchante et
en place et micro en place donc là c'est
le plan d' attaque c'est ça que c'est ça
vous voyez en fait tous les points
rouges c'est des caméras c'est à dire en
fait les caméras partout
onze caméras dans un petit espace elles
sont plus exactement
tu vois la planta bas il ya un micro
dedans voilà
voilà voilà et tout ça c'est à votre
service pour ce soir
l'équipe finit de camoufler nos onze
caméras cachées dispersés un peu partout
dans la salle
[Musique]
et pendant ce temps-là deviner ce que
l'on va aller chercher le plus important
la pac
voilà calypso je te présente anne à
notre experte enchanté bonjour vous avez
de belles choses belani
la particularité c'est que ces calypso
qui demandent son chéri en fiançailles
donc en fait on va être sur les bagues
aux hommes parce que généralement tu
arrive bien à te décider oui ça va bon
ça va tu as une petite cité une
préférence un autre simple avec un petit
diam hamas et c'est intemporel ouais je
pensais c'est discret ça va traverser le
temps c'est une très beau je crois qu'on
va prendre celle ci c'est bon calypso
oui c'est bon pas de juger allez adjugé
vendu
félicitations les magnifiques vraiment
bravo bravo à vous
pas ou si notre complice et meilleur ami
de karim arrive au restaurant il ne se
doute absolument pas de ce qui l'attend
toutes les caméras sont braquées sur lui
que le spectacle commence
deux personnes c'est ça
[Musique]
pour les deux lots la pétillante ou 49
coraggio cessera garde au parquet je
vous laisse regarder vers vous avez un
sens mersen
téléphone l'attention
récemment
retrouvez votre
arbre ou et passionnant avec maurice
opération merci à ces eaux
et pas d'alcool et ou bien avoir en tête
de l'eau
car ça le vrai faux on this topic
pourtant ce
nom à la
longue et juste juste juste juste de le
trouver maintenant vous êtes tous là
la péniche ça
c'est le dernier iphone ça en plus
on se refuse rien
oui normalement oui
je ne connais
pas et je
suis désolé album et ya pas d sociaux en
bas vous 3 on est là nos romans parlera
un peu de vos choix
par contre si j'y pense pas tout d'un
coup je suis un peu embêté parce que
oui dites moi
oui décrochez
pas de
noms mais on est au frais les pattes
aussi c'est comment
- karim et faouzi
c'est ce problème qu'on ne résoudra
pas de soucis à tout alors l'association
kevin et personnalités qui va nous
arriver
c'est son fils
de match
ratée match engagé pour le prochain
match
[Musique]
et c'est assez les équipes si tu veux
entendre
quoi ça s'écrit des champs d es
chandrayyan-1
sa famille
ont répondu
oui à l'eau
mais qu'est ce que tu fais sortez de ce
que j'attends l'auteur
c'est qu'il a ses racines mais qui êtes
vous non excusez moi on a trouvé le
téléphone et dj
nord non non on est des collègues on est
des amis
parenti
c'est pas vrai c'est grave
ils se connaissent par yves camus c'est
grave quand même
et
bah je vais pas répondre à tout le monde
non donc partie du débat c'est pas des
champions on a trouvé son téléphone dit
rappelé après un oui à l'eau
mais c'est pas didier c'est s'est déjà
retrouvé son téléphone il va arriver
dans une demi-heure
imaginer
c'est de le trouver c'est qu'il a didier
théron l'on choisit j'arrive là
raffut terrain c'est une blague
mais il n'est pas là you l'arc danse
elle arrive dans une lumière c'est lui
qui link library de la caricature à son
sari
pourquoi tu te vois tu dis j'ai envie
d'y être c'est bon mais tu mangeras avec
nous alors
c'est
une blague aux fortes
qu'est ce que ça fait de millionnaire
enfin d'intel serait pas conviée
attention attention
[Musique]
olivier pla
rapports d'écouté posture c'est vrai nom
est bien menée c'est quoi l'histoire
vous êtes des pentes à 10 des
[Musique]
noms
d'employés qui il arriva et la rue ces
mots là mais bon comment ça va s'cauet
non
car il
[Musique]
[Rires]
attend de moi aussi je vis
[Musique]
beaucoup à dire sur la poteau à venir si
vous allez on y va
vas-y c'est cool la magnifique reste pas
trop dur pour l'animation allons juste
pour l'aja matin
je reste
aux photos je suis avec stérile
avantage tous les postes
bonjour ça va il est très souvent
ils ont volé à clairefontaine vous à
tout ce passe bien mardi c'est une
blague mais non mais non c'est pas une
blague moi aussi je crois cette blague
[Musique]
ouais
bah là où je suis je suis autant
ya là bien là
en première mais tu viens au bout de 10
secondes ok je dis que j'ai avec une
copine et puis après sion ok à tout
les français mais on y va ça fait une
halte tous les manger
abel et l'a
[Musique]
donc là karim tu te doute de rien
je me doute de quelque chose mais je
pensais pas que c'est calypso calais
venir je me disais quand même les appels
y en avait plusieurs capter bon ça
pouvait être un téléphone effectivement
le téléphone de didier deschamps ça peut
se tenir oui parce que j'ai vu la photo
de déverrouillage c'était nuit son
office
c'est possible mais après je pensais que
tu es fauzy qui me faisait une caméra
cachée d'accord je me suis dit il ya
vraiment des gens qui vont venir au mois
on va discuter maintenant parler de tout
mais je pensais pas du tout que c'est
donc fauzy c'est son meilleur ami voilà
ça quand tu vois que dans le resto ya
cyril hanouna qui vient en chair et en
os tu le vois d'habitude tu le vois à la
télé et là il arrive tu dis quoi ça m'a
surpris mais je me suis dit là c'est
vraiment une caméra cacher
voilà les appels tout ça ok je me suis
dit là laquelle charles ya quelque chose
là et là tu tu es ce que tu imagine ce
que ça peut être pas du tout et calypso
toi ce moment là tu es dans quel état
d'esprit franchement je stresse un peu
de sa réaction j'ai vu que la caméra
cachée elle s'était bien passé donc déjà
ça m'a rassuré j'avais peur qu'il fasse
une connerie ou quoi d'affaires qu'il
fasse quoi mais je sais pas je me suis
dit entre eux mais quand tu parles entre
eux au times en parler de femmes c'est
vrai
nous c'est la même chose vraiment quand
on est entre filles on parle des gares
allons
donc avait peur de ça ouais je me suis
dit bon il faut pas trop qui se confie à
l'un à l'autre se re
était très sérieux ça prouve toi ça
prouve que tu as choisi le beau c'était
une surprise de taille justement cette
demande en mariage c'est vraiment un
truc de dingue regardez
[Musique]
on y va ça fait une halte tous les
manger je suis venu avec une petite
douche on lui cherche à bâle et l'as
tu crois qu'il a vraiment un message
passe n'est pas comme si on va être 3
bientôt a donc j'ai fait tout ça pour
savoir si tu veux m'épouser
[Applaudissements]
à
et
m
jallet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
franchement
bien fait de mettre ce qu'il voulait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
karim petite surprise pour tâche est
venu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va
deux doigts
[Applaudissements]
et on a un autre cadeau de films tu le
sais c'est qu'on va vous envoyer en
week-end ou les deux pour vous reposer
parce qu'elle a dit qu'elle arrêtait pas
de dormir de quoi pouvoir se reposer
compliqué et on vous offre plein de
cadeaux pour le petit qui arrive bien
entendu c'est de la part de destinée
mois ouais parce qu'on adore faire des
cadeaux comme on ne sait jamais tous les
deux bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que ça vous fait de revoir ces
images est mignon
et karim toi comment est ce que tu as
vécu le fait que calypso te demande en
mariage à c'est une belle preuve d'amour
jérôme rey
dans la nuque on est rentré jeudi
franchement c'est magnifique qu'est ce
que tu m'as fait n'en revenaient pas il
est quand même heureux dire en quoi ce
que tu as fait un truc de fou mais oui
mais c'est un truc de fous toi c'est un
mât de 26 pardon elle m'a devancé heldt
a devancé qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter aujourd'hui
un bain d'être d'être heureux en
guadeloupe que je puisse avoir ma
mutation et travailler là bas est
installé sur le long terme
génial merci beaucoup nous avons fait
partager ce moment merci avant c'était
vraiment chouette on a on a bien bossé
tout les deux car on a tous bien préparé
on a tout donné on a tout donné j'ai
rien vu en tout cas merci beaucoup pour
l'émotion que vous nous avez donné je
vous souhaite tout le meilleur soyez
heureux au soleil les pieds dans l'eau
a3 a4 a5 pourquoi pas en temps